he does his own stunts he didn't trust
me what do you think about like when Tom
Cruise is always like I do all my own
stunts and you're like dude take a
[ __ ] break
like well I know a couple things about
him one is I've done I've spent a little
time with him yeah hey kin his body and
believe me like him like he we did this
reading and I um that's how I am and
he's walking in front of me and he's
thick he's [ __ ] thick on cruises oh
dude he's five eight five nine but he's
he's wide like his shoulders he's got
traps and ditches he's never stopped
working out
he's got wide hips and thick legs there
is yeah look at that
oh he was what did that photos no yeah
what is this I don't like what that is
that's not real no it's not real but
he's he's a [ __ ] wide man and he's
never stopped working out fire hydrant
man he was a wrestler too by the way was
he yeah
Disney from like Syracuse New York or
something I don't know he didn't know it
damn he's shredded that he's never
stopped working out in between takes
Artie Lange told me that he would jump
rope he's jumpy he's always jumping but
is he happy well he's never made a
relationship work yeah I don't know I
feel bad because I really think he's
from what I know about him which is very
limited but people I do know who work
with him for a long time he's the nicest
man in the world yeah it's the [ __ ]
lady I love Tom I just think maybe he's
either
I don't know as he gazed he not is he
not is he asexual he's he lives he's
probably gay and he's probably it's
probably you know I mean no one reacts
the way he jumped on the couch with
Oprah when he found Katie Holmes that's
like I know it's crazy is he's a good
actor so that was even good acting that
was weird
that was like a bad performance but he
is probably gay and probably trapped in
the Church of Scientology I'd said I
think that but he's a great actor man I
love I love him in Magnolia I love when
he does kind of like a serious turn I
love him in he's all those awesome I
love him in pretty much every movies and
I bet I do I'm a huge fan of his I
really am I think he's I think he's such
a look at look at the [ __ ] body on
that [ __ ]
you know good luck good luck being as
excellent as he is for whatever reason
though I think he sold all his property
and moved down a Clearwater Florida
really yeah and he lives
that on the Oracle is he bought a bit
top two floors of a building that
Scientology the cut the church owns and
God that's good that's how it lives man
I wonder what his relationship what's
the name of the guy who runs Scientology
again David what's his name the guy who
wrote the book right he must be so
that's another must be so lonely but so
my a friend of mine spent six months
with him on a movie and yeah yeah well
that guy's yeah but they have like a
weird thing I bet I bet Tom Cruise much
[ __ ] hate in my bed John Travolta
must hate him nobody nobody hears from
that guy he seems like a scary dude man
I don't know oh yeah that's creepy
yeah no no not from where I read going
clear and if there's any to that book he
does not seem like a good guy not a good
person seems like a real [ __ ]
sociopath look at him yeah looks he has
like a nazi vibe oh there was like I was
like a cleanliness and like like an
order to which he has that reminds me of
like a not well in me he's a short guy
and apparently he suffered from asthma
as a kid and was very muscular like look
like Lou Ferrigno or something no he was
young everybody yeah yeah he's he's a
big smoker I guess I don't know is he
yeah he looks like he'd also be like a
game show host - yeah I don't know he
doesn't he's not he's not painted in a
good life but he's also he just he's not
around he just disappears yeah the dudes
in the shadows are the scary ones yeah
he's absolutely a shadow Church
Scientology has been exposed by the
internet and the problem is that it was
really really exposed you know and so
they're of their membership is way down
and they they're not able to do that
anymore yeah so I don't know I don't
know man although every religions got
this problem I guess but uh but yeah
they seem extra creepy the way they like
follow you and [ __ ] I'll say this about
Jews we don't recruit the way
Scientology does and you know no yeah
his dad his own dad went bad on them
though did he have it yeah on Roman so I
don't know man the way they what they
did with Tom Cruise and no because
Nicole Kidman's father was a
psychologist right yeah I think that's
kind of that was a term that they use
it's like toxic people or something no
it's called a potential trouble source
okay pts III I was in an acting class
with a lot of Scientologists really yes
and my acting class is written up in the
book going clear so you know I mean I my
teacher
Milton Katselas who then left the church
and then I couldn't see him where all
the [ __ ] actors went yeah people from
the church left and I was like what's
going on here the whole thing was really
weird I can't be around it I'll tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]